the emotions the feelings that you
experience
so what is the nature I
hope
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what happens next in the I don't I don't
I don't understand the sketch I don't
think I what do you what do you mean
it's Edward Scissorhands I I I don't
know what that means we put mugs on
everything I I yeah I know I have the
mugs on the hands
just like the movie but what
does the sketch go from there I I don't
understand it
uh is it me I don't I mean I'm not I
appreciate you guys put on the the work
I
what does he do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is what we call a disaster start
because uh my headphones weren't working
hold on so we have to fix something
really quick but I'm glad to be with you
[Laughter]
because I need to mirror my iPad so
these guys can see what's going on here
uh Yakuza they're working on it all
right uh our last show by the way before
the break because tomorrow we have a
Thanksgiving
special which changed my mind
about Thanksgiving yeah it's not exactly
like Happy Thanksgiving Charlie Brown
it's just no it's about there are only
two genders change my mind ah okay a
little bit more information there are
only two gingers do we got it working
okay there we go all right you guys can
see okay perfect this whole time
everyone can see mine's a little uh
Edward Scissorhands right now cabinet of
Dr Calgary you know what it is is uh
Yakuza did a great job with the
Christmas decorations yeah yeah yeah
buddy messed everything up in the studio
yeah that's true do you pay a price I'm
sorry so glad to be with you we're going
to be talking about a lot here today
we'll be talking about the Iranian uh
World Cup protest not to be confused
with the virtue signaling from all of
the other gay Europeans who wanted to
wear their gay bands but then when the
uh
the feet is it FIFA FIFA guys FIFA said
you can't wear the gay armbands this is
in a Qatar they uh you know they kill
gates are like that's okay we didn't
want to wear those armbands anyway
armbands what are beds what armbands
wait you know what we should do is we
should make them we should make the gays
wear the armbands they said let's see if
they can fly yeah don't armband me and
then uh we'll be talking about of course
we have a Biden pardon some Thanksgiving
turkeys which is fun uh also what's
really happening here's the theme today
okay
um I've talked about this quite a bit in
the past is awesome I'm getting Echo no
okay yeah everything's just a little bit
screwy today it's okay
um I mean it's not okay but it's okay
but it's not okay but it's okay
the media you know people talk about the
election stuff going on and we will
probably have Kerry Lake on at some
point here between Thanksgiving and the
New Year looks like there's some stuff
actually that's going to happen in
Arizona we want to wait until we get
some confirmation on developments but
before we get to any of that what's most
important is understanding that the
media does enough
that the media interferes with elections
enough it is and you need to try and
preempt that you know an ounce of
prevention is worth ten thousand pounds
of cure is that what it is something
like ten thousand pounds of defense is
what they say in sports so to give you
an idea remember that missile you heard
about the Russian missile in Poland
turns out that was complete total horse
crap didn't happen uh and that came from
the AP which is the single most reliable
news wire it's what all news sources use
for their daily updates
and then it was reported as though the
same AP by the way who said that the
hunter Biden laptop story was Russian
disinformation which would have affected
the outcome of the election there's no
doubt about that
and now it was confirmed by CBS so
that's enough and so sometimes when
people ask hey what do you guys do well
I'm not running for office no one here
is running for office but
counterbalancing that in the media that
to me everything is Downstream or
Upstream whichever term you use I don't
I still don't fully understand the
colloquialism
you know what comment below is it
everything is Upstream everything is
Downstream what do you think it is
everything is Downstream from well if
you pee in the river is it going
upstairs is everything Upstream from
culture is everything Downstream I hope
it's going Downstream is it Upstream is
it down drinking water somebody let us
know the point is the hierarchy
oh
I think you wanted it to go with the
current yeah yeah you don't want your P
to go a different way than the current
yeah I don't know can't but I did watch
Spider-Man and I know that if you put
the bottle of water uh underneath some
rocks with running water it acts like a
natural filter yeah didn't didn't fix
the E coli though I still ah no it turns
out you shouldn't use a dirty sock as a
filter no I learned it the hard way
so there we have that comment uh and let
me ask you this too what do you think is
the dumbest virtue signaling that's
going on the World Cup is just
absolutely perfect because it's soccer
and it's gay enough but it turns out
it's not gay enough
and the Iranians are not happy about a
lot either but think about this for a
second in a row the Poland right
remember Poland we covered it here even
on this show the okay the missile in
Poland right I think Donald Trump Jr
talked about it yeah
why would they lie about that well it
turns out that it was wrong there was no
vetting and uh the retraction doesn't
Trend the trend is already done for 10
hours number one Trend all over social
media That Could set off world war three
very big difference between Poland when
you're talking about a NATO Ally yeah
very big difference we've talked about
that on this show if something happens
with Poland shit's about to pop off
turns out it was false have you heard of
the retraction
have you heard now about the hunter
Biden laptop being 100 legitimate these
changes affect elections these changes
affect World governments and they are
being affected by people who hate you
they hate everything about you so that's
what we're going to get into today uh
out of that and more Ticketmaster Taylor
Swift because it's a gay theme how are
you Gerald eh I'm doing well how are you
I am doing okay you got less sleep last
night but you feel more rested today
well I had some wins because of you
yesterday some personal wins well thank
you for that he has very tender hands
yes he does they're soft he's a very
considerate Lover he is I am not but he
takes the reins when he needs to you
know he wears the pants or doesn't right
I mean he wears the half pants yes the
short pants yes the knickers knickers
okay with a k
all right
hey so before we get to any of that uh
by the way I don't know if you know this
research has shown oh sorry Dave Landau
is your fastest man on his feet Dave
Linda how are you Ahoy good how about
you I'm okay I feel better today yeah I
feel a little bit better today nice I
assume it's because I ate crap last
night do you ever find you feel better
after like a couple of drinks and you
eat crap and the next day you feel
better you mean like the Cheesecake
Factory I ate at 10 p.m did you yeah
well what's so sad about that is I know
you didn't go to Cheesecake Factory so
you you Uber Eats Cheesecake Factory
four thousand dollars
did the guy delivering it just look at
you with judgment I was like here's your
pie and then you flicked one of my tits
like
enjoy it tons of fun it's very rude did
it hurt enough for you to go
all that really chanting sounds
[Music]
I've heard you before I love your shirt
by the way show it oh yeah sure that's
one of my Hallelujah
that's what it's one of my favorite
quotes from that movie Oh I thought it
was Joe Biden on that shirt oh it is
look we've started we sell this shirt
let me get right into it here research
has shown the testosterone levels and
men have dropped nearly 25 percent over
the last quarter of a century really I
blame BPA plastic also I blame the
estrogen injections directly into men
yes you know it's it's all estrogen
injections these days kids so uh 25 of
the last quarter century and here's
something that you may not have known
this guy is responsible for 24 of it
totally sustainable bug burgers in 10
minutes start by grabbing some add dried
bugs on Amazon these grasshoppers cost
me just 12 pounds and provide me with
all the protein I need for the week
without destroying the planet get the
bugs into a bowl and break them down
blend them into a powder this is our
protein base next cook a handful of rice
and simmering water while that's cooking
add some seed oil to the bugs and stir
then some flour sustainable is best then
we add our bug mix to the rice give that
a second to blend boom bug Burgers use
your hands to shake the Patty then just
fry until Golden Brown Beautiful cut
some garnish and look at that
it's weird when we're saying the same
thing like look at that we're going look
at that I like my medium rare yes yes
was that like a two ounce Patty I'm or
yeah exactly that entire bag would not
suffice for Crayola Dave I mean he would
put that on top of his cheesecake you'd
put that on top of his chicken piccata I
would and then I would go I don't want
this yes exactly it's tastes like
grasshopper put it off to the side if
it's not escargot I'm not eating bugs
and here's the thing I get it if you
want to eat bugs fine whatever look you
do you but the problem is that they want
you all to eat bugs the problem is that
you're going to get government subsidies
four bucks the problem is that it's
going to be just like the USDA I don't
know if you know that's McDonald's use
beef Tallow in their fries turns out
that's better for you than hydrogenated
vegetable oil they switched over because
of the Neo environmentalist vegan back
then it wasn't a thing vegetarian Lobby
before it became trendy and now you end
up with all of these trans fats and it's
worse for you here's something else do
we really think that we know how this is
going to end up I mean you do understand
that bugs are a part of the ecosystem
system right I get it they're farming
they're farming grasshoppers now and
then of course in five years you're
gonna have someone asking for for wild
caught grasshopper
free range grass yes you don't think
they have anything to do with the
topsoil bugs you don't think they have
anything to do with the ecosystem keep
in mind by the way Krill was a perfect
example this you know krill oil it was
basically used as pet food filler right
it was a sustainable alternative to to
fish oil they were saying because it's
plentiful it's the most renewable
resource in the world now there's worry
about a threat to the Krill population
how much do you want to bet that that's
going to happen with Grasshoppers and
you can thank is that Beyond whatever
Beyond [ __ ] I don't I don't know
what it is but I do know that I always
heard the rumor of Dave Thomas using
mealworms I don't know if it's true well
whatever it tasted good yeah yeah
whatever I don't care at all he seemed
to master the bug the Arts of bugs and
beef mashup yeah what bothered me about
him was that I don't I mean I don't
think his daughter was at the age of
consent when he put her on in her most
unflattering light on every single Wendy
sign no no she well she was also as she
got older a little uh she ate a lot of
wind yeah she ate a lot of Wendy's yeah
and you're like but the point is he kind
of set her up for failure with that he
learned from the colonel yes you know
that he did yeah that's why he did
because the old Colonel's so good one of
the herbs and spices yep mealworms yep
you hear all those urban legends as kids
you know comment below the urban what
was the other urban legend that we used
to hear remember they they put stuff in
the McDonald's Patty to keep you from
throwing up yes remember they used to
say that yeah what's the term in English
in French it was an empty vomisa like an
anti-uh what's the term for something
yeah I don't know the actual Terminus
for uh but that's the total opposite
that makes you found but if you drink
alcohol never mind I've been court
ordered to do too many things to know
what you're talking about we have
epicock here for sketches that we wanted
to do and uh our half asian lawyer Bill
told us no that would actually be
vandalism
don't you remember the epicock of the
DMV sketch what we wanted to do no oh
we'll talk about it on my club okay hold
on let me write this down
down as we get to Gerald no Sports
what
[Applause]
how do you spell epicock
I'm not gonna say it okay
I believe that that's the new Disney
plus yes exactly they brought back Iger
they did I know well that's what happens
when you lose all your money yeah old
Bob
Tim Allen when they were like we don't
need you then Buzz Lightyear tanks and
they're like we're sorry about that yeah
can you do a Santa Claus series he's
like he didn't get enough with Santa
Claus three yeah oh boy by the way I p e
c a c i p e c a c i was way off
I I pretty much just I did a Hooked on
Phonics version and it could also just
be a porno passport
all right so Gerald knows then you talk
boy because I remind you later yeah five
thousand dollars this goes for now on
eBay yeah this is an authentic talk boy
it's the silver tuna baby the silver
tuna tonight all right Gerald you know
Sports I do and you don't consider this
a sport so I appreciate you allowing
this to happen I consider it a sport I
also consider it an embarrassment two
things can be true that is true FIFA so
World Cup started and uh things got say
it again FIFA FIFA World Cup oh that's
verbal epicock for me it is it's uh
billions of dollars though right so
prior to the Opening match at the World
Cup uh Iran played England and they
actually did a little bit of protesting
yeah they refused to sing their own
national anthem good for them
[Applause]
they're all thinking of being beheaded
when they go home yeah it seems like a
bad idea better than boarding Flight 93
yep that's made a huge mistake yeah
they're all off of work
is everybody else doing it hey it's it
looks like uh looks like hijacker Andrew
Tate
if they were all murdered right well and
here's the thing we're joking of course
but here's no that actually takes balls
for them to do that yes it does because
they are protesting I mean the unjust
murder we'll get to that in a second
right of the protesters right of the
protesters uh it takes a little bit more
than the armband right it takes multiple
balls to do what they're doing a little
bit more a little bit more
um unfortunately though you should note
uh this is the problem players don't
have all that much power right it's the
people in charge it's the suits and
you've heard me talk about that even
sometimes on the conservative side not
just when we're talking about the
political establishment but even when
you're talking about the media on the
left and on the right the suits aren't
necessarily lined up with you the suits
in the soccer league are not lined up
with the players and so the protest fell
on deaf ears because FIFA brought in
someone to pinch it and sing the
national anthem anyway
thank you
[Music]
that's beautiful Gerald give us an
update here though
nearly 400 Iranians have been killed for
protesting the death of a 22 year old
Masha amini right and so we've seen this
happening all over the world people are
protesting this about people are
actually being killed but it goes a
little bit further than that you're like
oh okay so people are being killed in
the streets that's bad enough well when
Parliament gets together like the
Iranian Parliament did and basically
says yes you need to execute the
protesters well that's that's pretty bad
that's not just like the Ayatollah being
crazy and going out and murdering people
that's all of parliament being like yeah
we totally that they should be killed
could you make a point there because I
come you know I was Raising Canada wave
a parliamentary system for all this talk
about democracy dies in darkness well if
you understand what a parliamentary
system is there still is a component of
democracy some people would say it's
more democratic than really what we have
as a constitutional republic but it
doesn't really matter if Parliament can
still just order the execution of
protesters hey democracy can also be mob
rule infringing on the rights of the
minority yeah well in the United States
of America needs to stand with the
protesters more than than just tweeting
something out like AOC saying we stand
with you that's fantastic okay the
president just needs to come out and say
hey we stand with you guys we're going
to stand arm and arm with the protesters
here they're not doing that they would
give great comfort to these people
because their life is on the line so the
captain of the Iranian uh soccer team
the football team actually
addressed the situation in this clip
is
foreign
please do consider if you're not on
audio uh well actually let me just take
this moment to tell you this is a live
show Monday through Thursday 10 a.m
Eastern okay and we are on of course
YouTube but also Rumble nothing would
make me happy for those of you right now
you can go over and watch on Rumble if
you don't see us live on YouTube without
us telling you beforehand we are still
streaming live on Rumble and mug Club go
subscribe on Rumble uh that way you
don't have to keep checking in every
single day and of course audio Spotify
Apple there's exclusive stuff on audio
we're on all these different platforms
because we're in the process of
diversifying Yeah Yeah from the uh the
satanic pedophile cabal at YouTube
joking
now this is what he said for people
listening on audio in the name of God
creator of rainbows it mustn't be afraid
to aim a little higher love I want to
say condolences to all of The Grieving
families in Iran we want them to know we
are with them and by their side and
share their pain and again the problem
with the suits is they co-opt it
speaking of rainbows FIFA decided to try
and commandeer this and issue their own
statement
[Music]
well too much comment below
or just the right amount just I think
just right I think it's perfect it's
baby bear so the spices and herbs
working together all the mealworms fit
to eat I don't want to fly home with any
of them
so after his fight in Abu Dhabi we
talked about this vanilla daryu she
actually gave a similar speech right
except on a religious front it wasn't
just the protesting but basically
standing up to an authoritarian regime
where the protest will actually cost you
something not like in the United States
where you can protest and you can light
stuff on fire and they don't do anything
to you you can just say the wrong things
in Iran and they can kill you right 400
people being killed by the parliament
saying yes stress the department do that
please kill more more democratically
killed yes well
one might say Just Like Bernie Sanders
Democratic socialism and by the way hey
please if you're on YouTube right now
hit the like button not only if you
stand with these people obviously the
people who are because I say these
people because there's protest and
protest protesting protesters so it's a
little bit hard it's like it's like the
metaverse of protesting but also hit the
like button if you just want to let
banil Darius know he this guy deserves a
title shot and he is catching some Flack
for what he did in Abu Dhabi saying hey
there is truth in Jesus Christ the guy's
on an eight-fight win streak he's an
absolute monster in the cage and his
biggest problem is he's two knights he
doesn't talk trash yeah if he talked a
little Trash he might stir up a little
but uh we'll have him here on an Ash
Wednesday even though he won't smoke
that'd be great he's a solid solid
fighter yeah I think he'll stir more
controversy just talking about Jesus to
be honest especially with that yeah yeah
it's a good point it's unfortunate at
the same time that all of this happened
the FIFA uh well basically the captains
of some of the English and other clubs
around Europe decided that apparently
protesting for lgbtq aaip right they
couldn't fit it all on there so they had
to start all right all those rights they
we're going to wear an armband you can
fit it on a test holiday Army because
that's how you protest you or an
inconsequential armband for one person
just the captain of the team wears that
armband by the way so one guy running
around with it uh but FIFA actually said
well uh no you're not gonna do that and
if you do we'll give you a yellow card
and give you a fine and they're like no
we're absolutely gonna go ahead and do
this and that's that's just that's in
one day before I'm not kidding one day
before they're saying we will absolutely
do this and then Harry Kane actually was
one of the guys who was supposed to uh
to do it I don't know did you already
bring up yeah Harry Kane looking tough
right there with his one love honestly I
just thought he was a soccer player and
then they decided uh yeah that's not
their normal uniform no so you know what
a yellow card is it's basically like
there'd be no way of knowing it's a
heart with rainbows it's cool yeah they
were going to give Harry Kane a yellow
card to start the match which means he
can't foul anybody so egregiously that
he gets another one and he was like well
that's just too much I can't do that I
can't plan to that right so according to
Sky News the one love campaign was
originally initiated by the Netherlands
and aims to use football to promote
inclusion and send a message
you guys are gay enough you don't need
to wear an army and then he immediately
pulled it he immediately
also keep in mind this is not there are
a couple of other layers to this story
you know 6 500 migrant workers died
constructing these stadiums facilities
in Qatar I'm willing to bet that some of
the more indentured servants just so
people don't know more slaves on Earth
right now than ever in recorded history
over 40 million we've talked about that
in the past you can do something about
slavery now when people talk about the
evil history of America and slavery and
of course slavery is a stain on our
history make no mistake about that
everyone here right do we all agree
anti-slavery Dave don't know no joke
we're all anti-slavery jokes and Mud
Club yes we're all anti-slavery I also
have an uncle slavery it's still son of
a still happens
it still happens today and you're not
willing to wear an armband in the United
States they kneel for the anthem yeah
right by the way the country who has
liberated more slaves than any in the
history of mankind but they won't wear
an armband because that might offend an
Emerging Market just like with the NBA
what happened with the Hong Kong
protesters what about Disney for example
this is this if they're going to remove
the lgbtq AIP agenda a content from
Disney like light it's because light
year wasn't allowed in certain Asian
markets that's the issue they go where
the dollars are and I will tell you this
it's ugly on all sides I don't need
companies to be conservative I think a
lot of companies that present themselves
as conservatives this is why we have
very few sponsors in the show a lot of
companies out there that present
themselves as right wing are really just
fleecing you not all of them we have
some great people we work with of course
Walther of course good Rancher of course
Patriot Supply if I'm missing any of
course clear right yeah we keep them
very limited because we know these
people we know where they line up and
that's why we ask that you support them
if I put my stamp on it it means that I
am vouching for the Integrity of the
company but you know what I'm fine with
Dunkin Donuts Dunkin Donuts their CEO
said we're not Starbucks we're not
political and you know what they do as
far as chair they mostly do feeding the
hungry they do turkey drives they do
things like big brother programs good
you don't have to be right you don't
have to be right wing just
fight against the values of this country
and I'm okay with it yeah and they this
shows you their character right so these
guys are protesting what they say is
gross human rights violations by people
who are gay homosexual are against them
in Qatar right people who are gay and
homosexual and they're saying oh we this
is so important that we have to end at
one I noticed that you showed up
you're playing aren't you you had a
choice to go to the World Cup or not so
yeah apparently it didn't offend you
their deaths didn't offend you so much
that you couldn't go there and playing
too when any resistance came your way
you simply said okay that doesn't cut
that you don't have these values you do
it when it's convenient you virtue
signal the Iranian protesters by not
singing that national anthem could die
these guys don't believe what they're
saying yeah they're just doing it
because everybody says you should and
it's popular and you can put it on
Instagram and look tough for a soccer
player which is a hard thing to do yeah
and then you fold yeah these guys should
get beheaded yeah and you guys could
maybe be called uh homophobic or not uh
an ally on Twitter exactly this is how
you judge look the medal of a man is
judged by first off what does he do when
no one's looking when there's no reward
for doing the right thing but he's doing
it for the right for the right thing's
sake and what do they do when there is
something on the line
where they stand to lose something and
invariably with Hollywood and by the way
let's be honest professional sports
sports these are entertainment
organizations for sure invariably when
push comes to shove and it comes time to
actually take a stand with consequences
they slink out
they slink out
well they've been so many different ways
it's just pathetic at this point like
how do you know what anybody believes
but soccer players lots of practice with
the bending we were talking about the
Disney same with like Tim Allen where
it's like okay well we need you back now
sorry Buzz bombed so we apologize oh
let's get the old the old president back
let's do that like they don't care I
really wish that Tim Allen would have
told them to go screw themselves he
should have he should have said oh you
didn't want me then you don't get me now
I love it when he does that sound Gerald
no Sports come on
wide open three stars
[Music]
all right this is an American tradition
one that I don't fully understand I get
the history I still don't get it uh Joe
Biden former Vice President Biden took
part in the tradition you know it's an
annual tradition where you pardon a
Thanksgiving turkey on the clintons yes
no I wouldn't have pardoned them oh
right yeah Sally would have put them
through a wood chipper grab a turkey you
think they're pardoned it just wakes up
nailed into its coop
with a with a metal water dish over it
in the middle of the Sun so they can
think about what they've done
um the unpardens the turkeys yes
sorry pardon some turkeys on
Thanksgiving uh and one of them was
named Chocolate one of them was named
chip really yes
ignore inflation by the way and of
course he said a bunch of dumb things
which brings us to this week in Biden if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black votes are in
they're been counted verified
there's no ballast stuffing there's no
foul play
the only Red Wave this season is going
to be a German Shepherd Commander knocks
over the cranberry sauce on our table
how many turkeys you got down there you
raise it Circle this Ranch grows about
nine and a half million turkeys a year
God love you nine and a half million
turkeys
I tell you what that's like some of the
countries I've been to
imagine
this has to be boring boring boring for
these kids to stand up here
you're allowed to do anything you want
including go steal a pumpkin if you want
anything you want to do wait if you have
a problem figure it out whether you're
for me or Trump and you ain't black
do you do you Mexicans want to go steal
you probably want to take some go in the
house and take some silverware yeah
it's like the finest China something
like gold plated angles yeah you guys
need a nap yeah I need a nap there's
just a Lincoln use a spoon in there go
steal it I really like how industrious
you people are I don't know what you do
with the santis though oh yeah uh smash
a pumpkin surprise me
[Music]
this is still a pumpkin
Cherokee looks like Mitch McConnell's
yeah it's impractical silly neck can I
punch it yeah
I got you Jake can you bring up just a
freeze frame why is Gerard depardo
helping him pardon a turkey let's see is
the turkey is being pardoned by bogus
it's just nice to see that he's no
longer me too yes yes he's back I mean
honestly can you really meet to a
Frenchman no that's what I don't
understand
this brings us to uh the Thanksgiving
Day Parade uh this is happening again
it's a lot of fun we're going into
Thanksgiving uh you guys can comment
below what you're most thankful for
because you know it's a cliche
uh I'm thankful for you guys
[Laughter]
I'm thankful for the destruction of
soccer that I get to watch it unfold in
real time so uh obviously you have the
big Thanksgiving Day Parade it's a
tradition are you guys watching that
this year up
hell yeah
Dave you got a little too excited on
that buddy well actually here's the
thing they decided to change it up a
little bit with some of the balloons to
reflect you know 2022 they have to go at
times like a chicken that identifies as
a turkey like a liberal leaving Twitter
yes yes they have that I don't know how
you put on a float well I mean you could
with the arrow or something yeah there's
like well there's a minor attracted
Santa
it's a mass so it is liberal yeah oh
good and uh this one is actually for the
neighbors to the north because you know
they want to uh they want to Cozy up to
Canada they have a frosty Trudeau as one
of the new uh floats that they have yeah
oh my gosh yeah
happy black face nailed it
and uh there's no magic in that hat just
hate and maple syrup I have to go commit
a hate crime I'll be busy busy busy
uh this one is I don't know why I
remember all these things but by the U.S
taxpayers actually we have the uh we
have the Ukrainian Thanksgiving dinner
that's one that they're doing uh yeah oh
wow yeah oh I see just stuffed and we
all love Charlie Brown Christmas so now
they have to update it of course the
people don't feel left out they uh they
have boosted Snoopy this is when they're
real yeah which just
oh that Stock's not even there he died
three weeks ago
blood clot is just the size of him
you have a Woodstock sized right he grew
a second white shriveled Woodstock
so let's get to this by the way uh and
you can share this please share this uh
hit the like button if you're watching
on YouTube you can hit the rumble button
if you're watching on Rumble
um I'm really looking forward to getting
to some of these media stories with them
the missile in Poland I just can't
believe that no one is really tough I
mean I can I believe that person's
talking about it come on but before that
important things first uh last week
tickets for the Taylor Swift I guess is
the eras tour that's the important thing
yeah it's the air is tour they went on
sale and things did not go well for
Ticketmaster I guess more than 3.5
million fans signed up for like the
pre-sale and the demand crashed the site
the demand crashed the site kind of like
rumble on Election I understand we love
you guys but you know look
they've strengthened their services oh
yeah no one expected that they got
attacked too which is crazy yeah they
did they got the DDOS attack yes it's
tough people are really gunning they
don't want them to succeed no and uh
it's not it's not that I it's not that I
want them to fail I want for no one else
to succeed
I hate most people that's the same thing
if I use your Ticketmaster and here it
is so Taylor Swift responded on her uh
yeah greatest actor of all time that guy
chews up every single bit of scenery in
which he plays a part I don't get the
Daniel Day-Lewis thing no I don't either
uh Taylor Swift responded on Instagram
saying Bill the Butcher it's really
difficult for me to trust an outside
entity with these relationships and
loyalties and excruciating for me to
just watch mistakes happen with no
recourse I mean seriously now you'd like
draw the line on this she never cared
before so so let me just get description
to see the millions crashing the sites
yes I can't believe all of my fans went
to buy tickets yeah like that's what you
want to happen I wanted to crash the
site you want people to be able to buy
tickets and everything else and I know
people are pissed off about it and
they're saying oh Ticketmaster is bad
that would be reasonable but
Ticketmaster has a monopoly and now
needs to be broken up because the ticket
sales were too popular and crashes
exactly are you serious it's like The
Virtue signaling with soccer it's all
about the selfish motive I don't get the
Taylor Swift could go create her own
Ticketmaster yeah and by the way hey
just a heads up I hope that I hope
Ticketmaster doesn't do it to us because
you can still go get your tickets at
lotto's credit.com tour for our
remaining yeah Baltimore December 3rd go
crash that site baby I think that's the
only place with any tickets left or
crash it yeah yes that's unbelievable
feel free are you use Ticketmaster for
what's your upcoming show I got uh
Munhall Pennsylvania this Saturday is it
Ticketmaster uh it might be oh boy
Carnegie Munhall PA it could be I think
they just Ticketmaster actually it's
going to look like that scene with the
Pittsburgh Steelers game with Bane what
a lovely mom
so uh Taylor Swift is good Taylor Swift
looks better with me
so she's not the only one who's mad her
boyfriend keeps leaving
you better write a song about it rather
than making better romantic decisions
yeah keep a man yes please tell us about
how drama around you great ass so Taylor
Swift isn't the only one who's mad now
Amy Klobuchar because she needs to be
heard somehow uh race she's like she's
like the little chick who's like and the
mom's just like you don't get it worm no
[Laughter]
so she raised her own concerns about
Ticketmaster this is Amy klovenshire for
those of you who forgot her face name
and relevancy in 2010 Live Nation and
Ticketmaster were allowed to merge they
the combined company now has 70 12 years
ago so in truth I have no other choice
and that's what's going on there is a
monopoly
quickly and quietly bought so many
venues and Arenas so it is a vertical
integration that's why we are called the
justice department to look at this and
to look back at that consent decree of
which they have power over that consent
decree that is the most boring human
being alive through our deep part two
yes
Amy Klobuchar I mean she is aggressively
like she is she is Mission oriented
toward mediocrity Amy Klobuchar is the
Olive Garden of people
no one serves up mediocrity like senator
Amy Klobuchar with her asexual haircut
and face pulled tighter than a snare
drum she has all the warmth of aborting
school none with none of the moral
conviction
when she's not throwing staplers at
interns or eating salad with a comb Amy
inspires no particularly strong feeling
one way or another in the normal private
sector Senator Klobuchar would probably
be fired for sneaking airplane shots of
vodka during her shift at Target instead
she's a Millionaire on the public
servant's salary and will continue to be
until 50 years after she's dead
why because the U.S Senate when you're
here your mediocrity
she's so tone deaf [ __ ] will run that
as a campaign ad
she's like I love Olive Garden oh that's
nice the commercial they made it's spot
on and my favorite my favorite dinner
spot I'm actually sneaking airplane
shots to uh Thanksgiving yes I'm gonna
ruin everyone's time I have a flask
uh
let's move on to this so uh I don't know
if you know this you should know this
but um remember that story that we heard
about uh you know and this was from the
AP keep in mind this is why this matters
AP is the newswire that all other
mainstream news sources use they use
them during election night a lot of the
time AP sometimes popular elections AC
actually sends out results yes for
Arizona in 2020. I have a here we have a
I think I have a Joe Lewis fuzz on my
face it's just been bothering me so uh
we all heard this story it came from AP
the most legitimate news source as far
as this industry they consider AP kind
of the gold standard that's where we all
got the story that Russia had struck
Poland with some missiles and in case
you've forgot now first off
the story is bullcrap to begin with
right spoiler alert but in case you've
forgotten this is how the media ran with
that story last week U.S intelligence
says missiles have crossed into NATO
member Poland killing two civilians
President Biden has spoken on the phone
with Poland's president about the
situation Biden offered full U.S support
in Poland's investigation Ukraine's
president zielinski said this is a quote
very significant escalation of the war
and that action it's important
official says that Russian missiles have
crossed the border into Poland which is
a NATO member killing two people and of
course NATO membership confers
protection for Any Nation it means that
an attack on one member of NATO is an
attack on all of them this is the first
time something like this has happened
this triggers all sorts of questions
about what the reaction could be from
NATO I think we all know now about that
article 5 of NATO that any attack on a
Ally of the United States of a NATO
member would trigger some kind of
response from NATO the AP citing a
senior U.S intelligence official ears
pin has confirmed that a Russian missile
or missiles crossed their beans Poland
in a Border Town I'm glad they put the
stock reports that some people near a
grain elevator were killed
AP exciting a U.S intelligence official
there you go AP citing a U.S
intelligence official will get to the
level of vetting that had taken place
remember they just said wozlinski said
this is a serious level of escalation
keep in mind all of that rhetoric that
can set off World War III easily easily
or certainly an international conflict
maybe not on the scale of World War III
I don't want to be hyperbolic here's uh
the real kicker the missile if you don't
know was actually fired by Ukraine so
now we have this from CNN and all
references are of course available at
lotto's credit.com uh Paul Polish
president Duda told a press conference
that there was a quote high chance it
was an air defense missile from the
Ukrainian side and likely had fallen in
Poland in an accident while intercepting
incoming Russian missiles there's no
indication that this was an intentional
attack on Poland most likely it was a
russian-made s 300 rocket so Ukraine
fired Russian made comment below did you
know about this did you know that it was
false because I want to get to some key
points of information okay so the AP
fired this reporter
uh James laporta just now yeah
they issued an editor's note after the
fact that corrected the story yeah okay
because people read those now keep in
mind though they're firing him okay but
laporta just cited an anonymous source
that it belonged to Russia and then the
media said this is coming from AAP who's
uh they're they're citing American
intelligence agencies there was no
vetting taking place this was by Design
they easily could have made a couple of
phone calls they decided not to and of
course this made very few headlines now
this is what matters it's not just the
LIE uh proactively that takes place but
also the lies by Omission in this case
we have both we have a lie let's call it
misreporting I would tend to bet a
little of column a little column B yeah
in other words it is your job your
responsibility to try and be correct if
you're breaking something of this
magnitude it's not like you were
reporting on you know Taylor Swift's
Ticketmaster story that's true you like
everything deep throatish these days
though is a bit uh fake well yeah it's
uh some guy yeah exactly oh that's good
that's some guy but he's with U.S
intelligence officials so here's what's
so
um pernicious about this is November
15th right when the story came out this
story trended number one on Twitter from
1 40 P.M to 7 40 p.m and it was within
the it was within the top 10 for 10
hours
so for close to seven hours it was the
number one Trend and you can go and
check out the tweets oh this is what's
happening time to step in time to spend
hundreds of billions probably trillions
of dollars time to go in and defend a
NATO Ally right and we even had people
in this Administration if you look at
these tweets coming out from people who
were very official none of them vetted
anything also yet Poland Russia Ukraine
they were also in the top five Trends
all of social media was dominated by
this story now we contrast that with the
firing the retraction the editor's note
of laporte's firing uh it didn't Trend
once since it was announced hmm
it's odd
so think about this for a second think
about the kind of effect that that has
in public perception guarantee you
guarantee that people who don't watch
the show guarantee you that people do
not proactively attempt to educate
themselves still believe it happened
still believe it happened and of course
they'll use it to try and condemn Trump
well Trump wouldn't have defended her
what are you a Putin puppet hold on a
second were we all Putin puppets for
saying well let's just wait for some
more information
so after almost firing off World War III
no consequences for AP and according to
their own website it says more than half
of the world's population sees AP
journalism every day and this is
something I ask that you hit the like
button because the YouTube algorithm
says that we're dead
look we work in this industry we know
this yeah newswires like AP uh and
Reuters these are considered the gold
standard this is you know NPR gets it if
you listen to the NPR uh Morning News
update or they do it I think on maybe on
the top of the hour bottom of the hour
uh they're constantly citing AP ABC NBC
CBS CNN they're constantly citing AP if
AP says this is a story they assume that
it's legitimate Reuters is another good
example and this is not one of the first
well one of this is not the first time
this has happened I mean AP has a long
line of screw-ups you can go back you
can go check out our references but
Reuters is another one yeah Reuters is
another one that a lot of people trust
and if you don't know about this one too
you didn't know about this one specific
one you're going to talk about next I
didn't know about that well this is the
videos having been around for so long
and I've been here on YouTube since well
2008 doing political I remember I
remember this story Reuters deliberately
edited out knives and a bloodied Israeli
soldier from photos of uh this was a
flotilla there's a ship trying to reach
Gaza
so you can see the cropped version and
the uncropped version now that is a lie
that's deliberately saying let's get rid
of the knife let's get rid of let's make
sure that there's at best an equivalency
at worst we get to vilify the Israelis
when really you're looking at someone
with a bloody knife here
uh AP we have some other examples 2017
AP had to issue a retraction a story
that said 17 U.S intelligence agencies
agreed Russia interfered to help Trump
get elected remember that one
but you know we're talking about these
still running on that one well it's this
you know this you know pointing to an
expert or this Elite Class or a fact
Checker or somebody who's going to be
the Arbiter of Truth and saying well
they're always going to be right well
that's never how it works you've set
this system up and you've lied to people
here's my problem with this beyond that
that's bad enough people are trusting an
AP and trusting a new news organizations
you know who knew
zielinski yes zielinski knew from the
very beginning or at least from very
close to the beginning and thought you
know what here's an opportunity for me
to get more support I will lie and say
oh yeah Russian missile I can't believe
it never mind the fact that our
intercepting missile didn't do the only
job that it has is intercept another
missile it's a pretty bad interception
when in 50 miles into Poland it's not a
mundane detail is that a mundane detail
Michael much right goes into poll and
kills two people potentially could set
off World War III because the headlines
weren't just Ukraine Russia missile
Poland dead it wasn't that it was World
War III it was the U.S needs to step in
and help a NATO Ally right it could be
you're talking about potentially
hundreds of thousands maybe millions of
casualties if something like that
actually does get set off and zielinski
uses it for personal gain to say well
yeah the Russians are bad they just they
just attacked a NATO country shouldn't
you guys do something remember I've said
it's about it's [ __ ] fighting
[ __ ] as far as the leadership of
Russia as far as the leadership ship of
Ukraine just to be clear there are good
people in Russia and there are good
people in Ukraine I'm not taking aside
as far as the Russian people or
Ukrainian people but the leadership are
corrupt on all sides and like you said
zelinski the only reason that he felt so
comfortable doing that when he knew
better was because well he's just gonna
have another meeting with Sean Penn he
knew that the media was going to carry
his water hey where is that where's code
pink
where are the people who are calling
Bush a Warhawk and by the way I
understand where you'll line up as far
as the foreign intervention from George
W bush I'm not disagreeing with you but
where are all these people who made it
their raise on that and now zielinski
nothing nothing
you either have to believe that he is so
incompetent that he didn't check the
label of the missiles
so that in which case he cannot be a
leader of any kind of a of a country
this is an actor this is a failed
comedian who played a piano with his
dong that's his big bit or I'm right
here
yeah or he's dishonest either he's
incompetent or he's dishonest and the
media has that same decision to make we
already know that zielinski was being
dishonest we already know that this
reported AP was being dishonest the rest
of the media reporting from it well okay
you know what let's just say you were
ignorant but now you need to do better
why because this affects Global policy
this affects Allah and by the way
affecting Global policy as far as
American interventionism let's be clear
it's at your cost and a net benefit to
the rest of the world for as much as
everyone [ __ ] about the United States
and you have the greatest military well
were people saying oh my gosh a missile
went into Poland hey Sweden time to step
up
no we were looking at hundreds of
billions of dollars and sending in
soldiers from the United States yeah so
it's at your cost while you're dealing
with the horrible economic downturn
worst economic downturn really in modern
American history say for maybe 2008 even
then it's arguable depending on which
metrics you want to use but as you are
living and many of you struggling hand
to mouth you do have people in positions
of power who have a vested interest
again at at worst of vested interest in
global conflict because they benefit
that's that's that's really at best
and by the way this also ties into what
we're talking about election meddling no
not saying that the the ghost of Chavez
rake Dominion voting machines but what
happens with the media bias is enough
this is what people need to be focusing
on this is why Republicans who are
spineless who did nothing about section
230 who know what has been happening
with uh I mean look at gensaki right now
she's about to be basically brought
before a court because of the
misinformation guidance that came from
this Administration to Big Tech which of
course resulted in censorship
um
they affect elections and I think the
most important example we have this
right now which could have created World
War III but as far as domestically CBS
News the same place that we just showed
you reporting from AP they just
announced
just finally admitted oh uh the hunter
Biden laptop the thing that we also said
was Russian disinformation yeah right
like AP said uh turns out it's true
and as Republicans take control of the
house Hunter Biden the president's son
will be a target for investigations and
that means data from a laptop reported
to belong to Biden could be crucial to
the investigatory process CBS News has
oh it could be nothing like being two
years late to the party through a third
party or political operative but
directly from the source we provided it
to the FBI under subpoena and we
commissioned an independent forensic
review to determine its authenticity
you're confident based on your analysis
this is Hunter Biden's data
yes
we commissioned an independent forensic
review this was the review yeah yeah
that's just dick with Eminem's on it yes
yeah yeah same as it is Star Trek speed
dating yes yes yes I feel like the guy's
sitting there waiting for the question
and she says is it real
yeah of course it's yeah everybody yeah
do that you're doing a six minute puff
piece on I'm not kidding they go on for
6
minutes on the data being real I told
you a year and a half it just cuts yeah
now now now don't start yelling this is
nobody's fault yes it is it's your fault
it is 100 your fault no you can't let
this go on yes this is something that we
knew back in and this is what they do
Rudy Giuliani they say oh crazy and you
know what he says some nutty things that
doesn't mean that he's always wrong they
try and say oh this show oh look they're
far right wing sure it's an
entertainment show but we make our
references publicly available we knew
that this was true back in October 2020
when Rudy Giuliani shocked Us by showing
the actual laptop and also site well
I'll explain some context afterwards no
I'll just say it now I'll front load
this a little bit Marley we said to
begin with the FBI rated giuliani's
house and took everything except the
laptop that you're about to see which
has now been confirmed this is our show
October 2020. have you seen the pictures
have you seen the pictures of him with
the crack pipe
did John write a half oh wow does he
look does at least look like cool
unfortunately I can't show them to you
right now but this is the hard drive
they're on right there oh my word
like what yeah and afterwards I remember
we went to I went to the producers I
said like guys did you confirm that
that's the real laptop I'm like he can't
just do that on there if it's not the
real laptop they're like no no it's a
real laptop yeah yeah and now we know
it's a real laptop two years later I
remember that because it was the only
time Rudy Giuliani ever showed Hunter
Biden's laptop to us right yeah October
15 2020. if I remember correctly that is
prior to election day we had people
saying I have this laptop I have this
information come verify it baby yes we
can do the CBS thing but we can do it
before the election and the FBI decided
to rate his house and go through the
sugar cabinets what about this what
about this laptop nothing for me today
thanks no about this laptop you see
Hunter Biden's [ __ ] all over the laptop
and also the Ukrainian deals and the the
corruption but mostly there's so many
pictures of [ __ ] so we don't want it
it's like World War Z that we're going
around a sick laptop and yes exactly
yeah they're taking the plastic off my
furniture that's weird the laptop's
right here
[Music]
take note by the way of the original
Marvel the ridiculous worriness in the
CBS title to try and obfuscate this it
says oh yeah this is this is the header
copy of what's believed to be Hunter
Biden's laptop data turned over by
repair shop to FBI showed no tampering
analysis says let's look at that this is
what it should say
Hunter Biden's laptop Scandal verified
yes right yeah anybody on our team
writes a title like that and we politely
show them the door yes absolutely it
says copy so copy of what's believed to
be again it's not relevant no it doesn't
matter that's a copy is believed to be
Hunter Biden's laptop hold on a copy is
believed to be but you just admitted
that in fact it is 100 verified and uh
by the way we actually do have uh
exclusive BTS Twitter from the CBS
editorial board revealing your essence
how they came to this title
[Applause]
thank you
all right
we gotta find a way so nobody sees this
I
I got it
[Applause]
ah it's one of those no think tanks yes
and they don't believe in brevity and
this would matter by the way uh um no
wait this does matter sorry not this
would matter this matters the reason
that this matters I I guess I should say
this wouldn't matter if it didn't affect
the outcome of the election it's worse
than that not only do they lie about it
there was a there was a clinical level
of gaslighting where they tried to
accuse you and the then sitting
president of making up crazy conspiracy
theories when they talked about this
issue and of course
understood the validity of it remember I
think we have a clip here this is um CBS
is I always forget her name oh Leslie
Stahl interviewing then president Donald
Trump and he's in the midst of a scandal
he's not and he's taking of course he is
honestly come on of course she is it's
the biggest second biggest Scandal the
biggest Scandal was when they spied in
my campaign they spied on my campus
there's no real evidence of that of
course there is it's all over the place
Leslie say spy to my campaign and they
got can I say something you know this is
60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't put
it on because it's bad for biting we
can't thank you
very much I'm totally verified no it's
been just go down and get the papers
they spy to my campaign they got caught
no and then they went much further than
that and they got caught and you will
see that Leslie and you know that but
you just don't want to know as a matter
of fact I don't know that and you're out
why don't you get back to your interview
and let's go forget him for me
your president excuse me Leslie you
started with me excuse me my first
statement was
are you ready for tough questions are
you that's no way to talk
there's no way to talk
at this point he's one of our producers
interrupted to advise about the time
remaining in the interview I think we
have enough of an interview here hope
okay that's enough let's go
let's go uh
uh let's go meet for two seconds okay
thanks I'll see you in a little while
thanks
sir yeah be careful
oh that's throttling yeah be careful how
about you you osteoporosis written [ __ ]
bye
it's gonna be on a commercial with Sally
Field no there's no way no then two
years later Well turns out there was a
wacky yeah we just didn't want to do it
we were both hot in 1974. yes that was
it and even that's a stretch now
remember uh this all started uh on uh
October was October 14th 2020. we have
all the references available at 11 was a
New York Post article
and then the laptop the hunter button
laptop was showed on this uh program for
the first time a week later yeah like a
week later now the story from the New
York Post about the laptop which we now
know is 100 true
according to people who really really
don't want it to be true
the story was throttled by Facebook
and it was completely blocked by Twitter
on the run-up to the 2020 election which
by the way changed the election
according to Biden voters themselves
when polled we'll get to that in a
second this isn't if only this story
yeah not to mention the throttling of
everything else not to mention the
things like suspending the biggest
conservative stream that's ever existed
the biggest election stream that's
existed right before you go into
midterms or right before you go into
general elections there are a bunch of
other sort of satellite issues that
orbit but this alone was enough to
affect the outcome of the election even
assuming that everything else ran
absolutely swimmingly so don't don't
even forget oh that's right we have a
clip I forgot we have this Joe Biden
right he went on record in his debate
with Donald Trump October 20th and again
it's zelinski saying this is what you I
really hope that I'm communicating this
effectively and please comment below if
I am the same issue with zelinski where
he knows better zielinski knew better
and he went out and said that it was a
Russian missile anyway into Poland why
because he felt comfortable doing he
didn't fear any kind of accountability
or retribution for the media former Vice
President Joe Biden going into this
debate with Donald Trump on October
October 20th
knew better
he knew that the deals that were
discussed in the laptop were real and he
knew that the laptop was real why did he
deny it because he didn't fear any
accountability from the media zielinski
Joe Biden they're two sides of the same
coin here he is October 20th denying in
a debate to Donald Trump that it exists
Joe they're calling you a corrupt
politician nobody I want to stay on the
issue of Race
shop from Hell president Trump no we're
talking about race right now and I do
want to stay on the issue of race
because you lied about him being a
racist
former National Intelligence folks who
said that what this he's accusing me of
is a Russian plan they have said that
this is has all the Care four five
former heads of the CIA both parties say
what he's saying is a bunch of garbage
nobody believes it except them his and
his good friend Rudy Gianni you mean the
laptop is now another Russia Russia
Russia hoax that's exactly
so first off knowing what you know now
that should terrify you and second if
you have kids they should leave the room
okay I'm going to give you a countdown
five four just because about it we're
discussing age propriety it's not not a
trigger warning here
um
defund the [ __ ] FBI and CIA tomorrow
in doj yeah hey hey look maybe they
didn't know better
at best it's cowardice where they didn't
come out and say no no no no no that
that's that's wrong
at worst he was citing them and many of
them came out and said yeah yeah Russian
disinformation
it's not whether you have a country that
has laws do they apply it equally they
picked sides during a campaign now do
you believe that they didn't know better
do you believe that they didn't know
better and if they didn't know better
was that because they actively didn't
try like raiding Rudy giuliani's home
and walking around the laptop
think about that for a second when
people say it's an extremist point of
view to say we need to dismantle our
intelligence agencies that's why isn't
it their job to protect the American
people like I don't know maybe someone
who's beholden to corrupt oligarchs and
foreign Nations running for national
office if you don't do your job there
what purpose do you serve keep in mind
that debate was heard around the world
the media carried the water you couldn't
find the story on Twitter you couldn't
find the story on Facebook you were
accused of being some kind of conspiracy
theorist and now knowing what we know
and if people knew better according to
polling 17 of Biden voters would have
completely changed their Vote or not
voted at all if they had even known
about the laptop
which also means that a lot of Biden
voters weren't tuning into that debate
because they didn't even know about it
that's worse than that's worse than just
thinking it's false because that's what
Biden said they didn't even know about
it what if they actually knew that the
Biden laptop was real and that former
Vice President Biden lied about it hey
you know what how about a committee
there how about a hearing that how about
you put Joe Biden under oath and ask him
about that because if he were to say
that with the kind of accountability
that Donald Trump consistently would
have with the subpoenas that is perjury
and you could argue that kind of perjury
treason yeah absolutely how about the
five former heads of the CIA coming
forward and saying hey under oath why
did you think that was Russian
disinformation why did you make that
statement to the president or the person
former vice president right for
president at the time why did you do
that by the way notice what Joe Biden
said in that debate I don't know that I
picked up on this before nobody believes
it five former heads of the CIA when he
said it's oh it's Russia Russia Russia
again it's all probably that's what
they're telling me right he didn't deny
it himself he deflected each time to oh
no these people say that these people
say that these people that nobody
believes that lifetime appointments who
don't have to be elected yeah heads of
intelligence it's not real would have
been the defense it's completely made up
Donald Trump would have been the defense
but how many times has he had to pick up
his son on a crack Bender at his niece's
Hut that's the point so of course he
knew that it was true and he tried to
sidestep it and the media allowed him to
do so so according to the polls 17 of
Vine voters would have switched their
vote just this one story guess what that
would have done Donald Trump would have
won Arizona Georgia Nevada Michigan New
Hampshire Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Minnesota if that's 17 switched let's
say we're right on Michigan had another
cooler right yeah exactly real real red
wagon yes we have to make sure we get it
right yeah yeah
YouTube will hold us to a standard that
they don't hold the former vice
president that's a landslide that is a
landslide Electoral College victory
it's not even close if you go to bed and
we know who the president is and it
doesn't change overnight so election
fraud you know or what I would just say
is when you're talking about mail-in
voting issues you're not allowed to say
election fraud unless you're a Democrat
on YouTube but certainly election issues
as far as security if you're talking
about mail-in voting if you're talking
about uh curing of balance if you're
talking about making sure or voter ID
right this is we should be able to
discuss this on YouTube we should be
able to discuss this everywhere if your
proposals we need voter ID because we
need more safe and more secure elections
I know you're saying they're the safest
and most secure ever well we want more
safer and more safest and more securist
but
well I'd like to hear under oath why you
walked around a computer right yeah I
just want to put that yeah yeah like I
just want to know what the reason was
was that orders from above why did you
ignore that and if you're looking for
anything that would fit the description
I mean it's the it's the first thing you
would go for in any investigation would
be the person's computer yes period yeah
that's the first thing you ask for you
don't go through his Pantry no you know
what's in your computer the moderator in
that debate by the way yes let's go back
to you being a racist Mr President yeah
because we've said it even though we
have clips of you saying the opposite of
that and black people really love you so
17 would have changed their vote if
they'd even known about the hunter Biden
laptop what do they mean no well when
you consider that a majority of
Americans get at least some portion if
not most of their news from social media
Outlets oh this is why they didn't know
Twitter completely locked out the New
York Post account until they completely
deleted the tweets about the laptop to
be clear
and then by the way Twitter backed off
and they unlocked the post Twitter
account uh the account itself
and last we checked I guess you can see
now the original tweet two years too
late because remember what they did was
they originally unlocked the account
only though if the New York Post deleted
the initial tweets now what what happens
that repost hold on that is the repost
that's nice look at pull that overlay
back up look at the counts on that
October 14 2020 is the date I know but
that's not the original counts on what
that that tweet yeah the world like
crazy yeah that might be all they have
though they could have been thrived well
they weren't they had to delete the
original one I know this is what
happened they did yes then Twitter said
hey hey delete the original ones and
we'll let you back on and now you can
you know maybe get the story out so we
can Shadow ban it now knowing what you
know Jill having worked in this industry
for a very long time do you get all
those retweets back no do you get all of
those likes back hey you ever heard of
an algorithm you ever heard of an
algorithm
is it a stretch for you to believe that
Twitter's algorithm favors likes and
retweets that makes sure that it's seen
that's why the algorithm exists you
don't get it back if they lock your
account and you lose all the momentum on
the original pose one post to begin with
yes one one post was ten thousand likes
and retweets it's worth far more than
two posts with five thousand each it's
an exponential effect it's a force
multiplier you don't get it back and
that's why well and they they gave them
time to come out and say no this is
completely false what they did is they
took it down you can't decide for
yourself you can't look at the report
for yourself but what you did have was
the President coming out or the vice
president running for president at the
time come out and say it you had five
former heads of the CIA come out and say
it you have people like Stahl saying oh
you can't verify any of that information
now you can repost your fake story do
you see that yeah all they have to do is
pause it long enough to get past the
news cycle and discredit it and then you
can say whatever you want to say because
nobody will believe you now yeah and so
just when I say that we are not having
free and fair elections and I'm willing
to stake my claim on this YouTube if
you're upset I am saying that we are not
having free and fair elections if you
have three or four companies
colluding to remove a key piece of
information that according to the voters
would have changed their vote that is
not a free safe and secure election that
is not and then come out especially if
you come out two years later and verify
what we already knew to be true I'm not
talking about voter fraud I'm not
talking about Joe Lewis voting in the
city of Detroit I am saying that I do
not believe we have a secure election
system if people who run a handful of
companies
can be more powerful than governments
and Link arms with governments which
remains to be seen a little bit more
what we already know again they'll
verify it with ginsaki in this
Administration working directly with
those on social media that is not
a constitutional republic if Twitter
Facebook and Instagram Google alphabet
and a couple of other companies can
determine public opinion simply by
ghosting one of the most important
stories in the election cycle according
to the voters themselves and then of
course they started walking it back once
they had done the damage and said well
you know maybe we're wrong about that
let's go through the list you have uh
back then he was still you know running
some stuff before the 4chan artist took
over uh Jack Dorsey on the story We
recognize it as a mistake that we made
both in terms of the intention of the of
the policy and also the enforcement
action of not allowing people to share
it publicly or privately we made a quick
interpretation using no other evidence
that the materials in the article were
obtained through hacking and according
to our policy we blocked them from being
spread
upon further consideration we admitted
this action was wrong and corrected it
within 24 hours okay let me ask you this
what's the further consideration
there
point the intelligence agencies had not
come out and confirmed it which they
have now after the election at that
point CBS hadn't confirmed it which they
now have after the election had taken
place and by the way also conveniently
even after midterms because it might
have played a role again yeah well after
what consideration
after what what
changed what was your Flash of Genius
moment Jack Dorsey oh oh you realize you
might actually be caught
and then of course we have another uh
hey let's call them they're basically
oligarchs they're basically big Tech
oligarchs is what these people are we
have Zuckerberg then walking it back
there was a lot of attention on Twitter
during the election because of the
hunter Biden laptop Story the news yeah
so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than Twitter
um I mean basically the background here
he douched out yeah I think basically
came to us some some folks on our team
linked to appeared human just so you
know like you should be on high alert
there was we we thought there was a lot
of Russian propaganda in the 2016
election we have it on notice that
basically there's about to be some kind
of questioning the results of the 2016
election there uh that's similar to that
so just be vigilant for the I think it
was five or seven days when it was
basically being
um being determined whether it was false
um the Distribution on Facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it when you say
the distribution is decreased it got
shared how does that work it basically
the ranking in news feed was a little
bit less so fewer people saw it than
would have otherwise so it definitely by
what percentage I don't know off the top
my head but it's it's it's meaningful
yeah I would say it's meaningful by the
way here's something important that you
note right there notice that we believe
that there was a Russian interference in
2016 so what they did was question the
legitimacy
of the 2016 election in order to quash
any questioning of the 2020 election
isn't that brilliant we questioned
legitimacy we all have many refuse to
concede that election of 2016. so
because of that we've put safeguards
into place including not allowing you
to question 2020
isn't that absolutely brilliant when
he's talking about Shadow Banning we can
tell you that we experience this all the
time on Facebook for example right now a
lot of crowder link the references to
this very show you can go and check them
out on our Facebook page on our own
Facebook page they reach very few people
we've tested other big Facebook pages
post the exact same links to our website
and they will get 40 times the reach
yeah because of something baked into the
code on our page and hey look that's
just us I get it
but when you're talking about presidents
you're about to say something I think we
just discovered something on air I think
our researchers are right and I am right
as well the research team is right
that's the original tweet okay but I'm
writing that when Twitter put it back up
they made them start from scratch they
made the original tweet start from
scratch so now if you look back
well I mean look at them no you're right
yeah that's very small if I go back and
go well hey they said they wouldn't let
them put the Tweet up they can put yeah
they did it's right here it only had you
know several thousand likes and and
retweets yeah and 10 20 years from now
we all have history teachers exactly
some people thought this should have
affected the election but it's
predicated on you know a tweet that went
up that only had a few hundred likes it
wouldn't have made a difference anywhere
they're not going to teach you about the
17 of Biden voters who would have
changed their vote let me tell you well
that's important though from that from
even what Zuckerberg said right and he
said look you can share it just not with
as many people it's like well that's the
exact problem is 17 of Biden voters
didn't get information exactly and
you're admitting to it right now
information that compromises our
national support 100 that's it's insane
for him but he uses all this language as
if you're not manipulating anybody right
you're not it's there's it's completely
transparent what you're doing well
unfortunately that's because you're an
intelligent individual it does work I
mean it does it manipulated a lot of
people well it's did it or did they just
not see it really you know it's like
they just hit it completely that's the
problem that you never get back right
you never can know the LIE of what
you've never been made aware and I will
say this you know what hit the like
button if you agree with me I'm gonna
I'm going to make a statement that I
mean without a hint of hyperbole I
absolutely believe
that these big tech companies are the
single greatest threat to the Free World
that exists today let me make the case
for you just based on what we've
discussed today because of big Tech
because of really a handful of companies
right you've got Google alphabet which
is YouTube and Google okay then you've
got Facebook which is Facebook Instagram
meta okay then you've got Twitter and
you could probably toss in apple and
Amazon into that mix all right
let's just go through what we discussed
today big Tech
trended for 10 hours
a false story with no vetting about a
Russian missile going into Poland in
other words they allowed to Trend at
best imprudently at worst in a way that
was deliberately subversive
the kind of story that could set off
World War III and then
they decided to proactively eliminate a
story that by all metrics and data we
have available to us would have not
maybe 100 percent change the outcome of
the election in 2020. I repeat myself
big Tech and really three or four
companies are the single greatest threat
to Western civilization and the Free
World
today so when you say what is it that we
can do hey well this is what we can do
and we don't know how long we'll be here
so it's a live show Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern nothing will
make me happier than you joining up at
Mud Club heading over to rumble if we're
not here go and watch them there because
we have the word of people who run that
company that they're not going to engage
in this kind of censoring and we're also
going to do an additional segment on
Charles Barkley because we need to clear
the pal a little bit a little bit it's
been a little bit intense biggest threat
to democracy
biggest threat to free I don't want to
say democracy freedom because as we saw
with the Iranian Parliament as you see
with a lot of the or as you even see
with Canada democracy can also just mean
voting to take away people's freedoms
you know like their jobs their
livelihoods freezer bank accounts if
some truckers decide to protest out
there in Canada because they don't want
to get an uh mRNA injection yeah that's
democracy no no big Tech is the single
biggest threat to what matters more than
just democracy freedom
Freedom it's a it's a constitutional
republic if you can keep it please hit
the like button share comment below if
you agree with that people talk about
Democrats Republicans I do think that
big Tech is the biggest threat that's
why we keep harping on it before we go
here to mugler we actually have some
behind the scenes footage for some of
you who don't know people here put in uh
put in some serious overtime hours and
burn the Midnight Oil and uh often these
big sketches only get used once so I
think we have some behind the scenes of
Edward mug Club hands which was far too
much time for silliness
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
[Music]
watch this and more at our other channel
Crowder bits
[Music]